this program is brought to you by Emory
University my name is Alan Kirk I'm one
of the transplant surgeons from next
door and I have the privilege of
introducing this session for dr. Linda
send Alice who is increasingly not
needing introductions around here which
is great to see in keeping with the
spirit of this retreat what we thought
we would do is try to bring you through
the landmark hand transplant that was
performed here in the context of a
university community because you know we
can practice surgery and medicine
anywhere why should we come to a
university to do it and and I think that
it's because that in a university it
allows us to ask the really important
questions and to try to understand how
medicine and surgery and the the crafts
that we practice interface with some of
the fundamental things of life like you
know who are we and as as transplant or
this question is really extraordinarily
important question because it it gets to
the point of who people are and and what
is just the scaffolding that allows them
to walk through life and we're finding
in fact that that increasingly we're
mostly scaffolding and and very remotely
a soul or an individual and and we've
been able to demonstrate that because
indeed almost everything now save parts
of the cerebral cortex are
interchangeable and that will I think
that brings up a lot of things other
than just the the sewing and like it
brings up the thought of how we coexist
as communities and a lot of the the
rules that we're learning to deal with
the immune system and to manipulate it
help us understand
how complex organizations work in
general if you can defend yourself
against viruses you can defend yourself
against terrorism that type of thing we
won't go there today but it is to say
that the types of things that we think
about frequently our fun are really
fundamental questions that are
applicable in a university setting like
this in fact transplantation was the
field that determined what's alive and
what's dead that up until nineteen
eighty there was not even an official
definition of who's dead and who's alive
and that of course comes into great
importance if you're going to be taking
parts from other individuals and using
them constructively to restore the
health of people who are ailing that you
have to have a fundamental definition of
death and and the fundamental definition
of death that we use now is one that
says that if your brain is dead then you
are dead but every other part is
optional in that regard just some food
for thought after lunch so the field of
transplantation actually has been with
us for four centuries if you go back in
mythology the the patron saints of
Physicians and Surgeons in the Catholic
Church or saints cosmos and Dominion and
this is a echar though oil on wood I
believe altarpiece showing the miracle
of cosmos and Damien which was really
one of the first limb transplants and so
people have been thinking about doing
limb transplants for as long as they've
been thinking about sharing body parts
and so cosmos was the physician and
Damian was surgeon and you can see them
putting on the leg of a recently
deceased more to replace the gangrenous
leg of a nobleman and the event being
blessed eventually they were beheaded so
so this is probably the patron saint of
trial lawyers or
but the the point is is that it has
really been obvious to people that we
can trade off and become interchangeable
but it was not until just the last
century that it technically became
possible to do so largely because of a
surgeon named alexis carrel whose mother
was a seamstress and he saw it quite
obvious that you could sew blood vessels
together and up till nineteen hundred
you couldn't and he actually witnessed
the king or the president president of
France get stabbed to death and bleed to
death and once they recognized that he
had been stabbed in his portal vein they
thought well there's nothing you can do
for that and he SAT there watch the
greatest physicians in France watch
their president exsanguinate and he
thought this is crazy and he went back
and he got some needle and thread and he
started working on you won the Nobel
Prize for showing us how to sew blood
vessels together any practice by trading
kidneys between dogs and cats and
noticed that after five days those
kidneys failed but they work for five
days and for the next 50 years or so the
biology of why that was why was that we
were technically interchangeable but not
physiologically interchangeable was
worked out and it basically long story
short came to the discoveries of Peter
Medawar who was studying skin grafts in
the Battle of Britain to try to save
pilots that had been burned terribly and
realized that it was lymphocytes and the
immune system and some genetic issues
that that caused us to be not completely
compatible and immediately people set on
that to understand how we can manipulate
that to to actually really make us
interchangeable and very shortly after
Peter Medawar work Jomarie did the first
kidney transplant in 1954 between twin
brothers they were identical twins and
they proved to be identical twins
because they did skin grafts between
them to make sure they wouldn't reject
before they did the kidney transplant
and then one had a kidney illness and
the other didn't and that started the
whole thing and it was a great thing if
you had an identical twin that didn't
have the disease you had which there was
only you know a handful of people but
his laboratory went forward to to start
working on how to manipulate the immune
system and this is sort of the favorite
picture I have of the team that first
did immune management to start allowing
people to be manipulated so they could
receive the organs of others as Jomarie
gertrude eliana and George Hitchings won
the nobel prize for the discovery of six
mo captor purine which was a drug that
this brash medical student named Roy
called had picked up from them and
brought to Joe Murray and said we should
try this so he did a kidney transplant
in this dog named lollipop and that dog
lived and within a year they were doing
kidney transplants and people and the
rest as they say is history indeed the
ability to transplant and the success of
that has grown with the ability to get
more specific manipulators of the immune
system and of course that went way too
far on one side of the spectrum such
that 10 or 15 years ago this was one
day's worth of medicines for a kidney
transplant patient and indeed that's
what got me into the field is this was
one of my patients and I looked at this
I thought this is crazy how can we ask
people to do this and so for the last 15
years or so myself and Chris Larson and
Tom Pearson and other partners here at
Emory have been working to change this
to to something that looks more like
this this is one of my patients now
that's the only pill she takes a day and
I have five patients now that only take
one medicine a month so our ability to
2-under more we understand it the more
we know how we can make us truly
interchangeable and the important aspect
of this is if now it is not so toxic to
transplantation you can start doing
transplantation not to save
people's lives but to improve people's
lives and when these types of
experiments started working I became
very interested in the topic of
composite vascular transplantation
vascularized composite transplantation
the transplantation of other body parts
hands and faces and things along those
lines and the I learned of a young
surgeon named Linda send Alice who was
in Louisville on this is her doing the
first hand transplant in the United
States and actually went visited
Louisville and was fortunate enough to
convince Linda that after having done a
five-year were four years in medical
school in five years of a surgery
residency in five years of a hand
fellowship that what she really needed
to do is to do five more years of
training so this is Linda with her first
two patients and actually Matt came and
addressed our surgical brand rounds
before the first hand transplant to show
us that I mean he is now a you know
fully integrated back into society using
his hands as I think he works as an
emergency medical technician and also an
inspirational speaker as well so Linda
was able to be convinced to come to the
NIH where we work together she was the
first fellow that I ever trained so I
feel exceptional pride in what she's
doing and when I was recruited here in
2007 the very first recruit that I asked
for was to have Len to come and join us
and so with that introduction I will
introduce to you Linda's analysis and
she can talk to you about the recent
fruition of truly interchangeable human
beings
Thank You long it's really a pleasure to
be here and as Alan said really the
advancements and the ability for us to
be able to move from a life-saving
organs to quality of life transplants
which is my academic interest is really
the result of the lessons that we have
learned from transplantation and people
groups like you know here at the emory
transplant center who have been able to
minimize immunosuppression so that we
can balance a little better the
risk-benefit ratio to receive you know
to improve people's lives and the
clinical need of these field which from
now on I'm going to refer to as PCA as
vascular as composite
autotransplantation is really fast and
we have seen that the military injuries
have really increased the number of
servicemen and women who require a
different type of reconstruction because
we have really modify the way that the
combat injuries have been because the
best that have been developed for the
abdomen and thorax has has changed
really the from lethal injuries to
surviving amputees and surviving people
with burn injuries but we also have
congenital malformations what these
could be applicable and we all already
know that the number one cause of
disability in the United States is due
to rheumatoid conditions so this is also
a potential application in fact the very
first time that I ever thought about a
hand transplant was in my last year of
medical school where I chose to do one
year of research and it was in
immunology or a mythology and on Fridays
was our multidisciplinary meeting and as
a medical student I was just sort of
looking at these patients with very
severe deformities and the hand surgeons
you know doing as much corrective
surgery as it was possible but it wasn't
as good as we would like them the
patients you know to recover
particularly on a condition which is non
curable and that was the first time I
thought
you know based pretty much of an
observation as a medical student I
thought well you know what if we give
them another option you know what if we
provide them with a hand you know
they're already on the immunosuppression
and that's you know probably how it all
started so based on the clinical need I
was you know recruited from the NIH and
I came at the same time that Allen came
and certainly in an environment like
this the first rational thing to do was
to perform a clinical trial on hand
transplantation to reconstruct the
injuries that could not be reconstructed
with like tissue in patients with below
the elbow amputations so we establish
the clinical trial we had not only the
IRB approval but we also established the
only program in the United States so far
with the VA system to include our
veterans and our service men and women
so we have the only program in the
United States in collaboration with the
VA system and as transplantation is
practice and one of the strengths that
we have at the transplant center is our
multidisciplinary up low approach and
hand transplant is is a complex
procedure and establishing
multidisciplinary approach for hand
transplantation is probably an even more
complex procedure and perhaps one that
that one only anticipate we never
anticipated complexity until we actually
established it but our program is a very
strong program we're professionals and
people are from the Emory transplant
center plastic surgery neurosciences the
veterinary services and the jerk is
where we do our translational research
rehabilitation and orthotics and
prosthetics from choa immunology
pathology mental health the hospital
services infectious diseases form the
department of prosthetic
the Georgia Tech's school of applied
physiology live link which is our organ
procurement organization Public Health
the VA research and development oral and
maxillofacial surgery radiology the
Mason house which is where we host our
transplant patients the simulation lab
immunology pastoral care bioethics the
Atlanta clinical and translational
Science Institute all work together to
provide our patients with even a hope
and better outcomes of what they have so
far and our history is long and we are
very proud of it we're very proud of our
etc' history performing the first
transplant kidney transplant in Georgia
in 1966 the first heart the first lever
the first pancreas the first lang the
first eyelid and in March were also
proud to add too many first by adding
our first hand transplant in Georgia
here at Emory and let me share with you
our first hand transplant here she is
remarkable 21 year old woman who when
she was one year old lost three limbs
both lower extremity as well as her left
hand due to systemic disease which is an
inflammation of the blood vessels so she
grew up without trillions 20 years later
we procured a hand in conjunction with
our organ procurement organization from
our very generous a gracious donor who
will not only donate at the hand but was
a multi organ donor the surgery took 19
hours we repaired 33 structures and we
had teams rotating throughout throughout
the surgery a remarkable moment is
really the moment of reanimation which
is
as you see here we connect most of the
of the structures and we release the
tourniquet we operate with the
tourniquet up to have a bloodless field
and to be able to under the microscope
repair in a very precise way not only
the vessels but the nerves and just to
give you a perspective of this the
suture that we use to do the artery and
the under nerds are as thick as a herd
so it has to be very precise when we do
this then we release the tourniquet and
the moment that we see this hand which
has been own eyes starting to get blood
again it's a remarkable moment for all
of us and this happened towards the
third part of of the surgery on that
historic day here at the University
Hospital we match for size gender skin
pigmentation and blood type she is doing
extremely well her nails are actually
growing faster than her contralateral
hand or at least she feels she you know
she the hair growth is a comparative to
her contralateral hand and she is in
intensive therapy per the protocol the
patient's day in the hometown which is
here with us for three months she's
staying at the Maison house and she has
therapy every day she's been doing
really well in therapy on week eight she
started already to you know play and put
all the cubes which are one inch cubes
you know one over each other to do
different things she also has been able
to manipulate marbles which are half an
inch and a different structure and and
round she's doing that very well and of
course raising her hand you know about
her arm to do things in the closet or to
start incorporating her hand in her
daily activities
and putting pegs which are accomplice
task and doing it after two months after
a hand transparent where she for 20
years they didn't have a hand it's
something that it's it's a it's not only
rewarding but but it's inspirational and
also gives us the opportunity to to open
the horizons for many other
multidisciplinary areas like
neuroplasticity like rehabilitation like
immunology to move forward other fields
and to incorporate really into into the
benefits of humans really moving forward
in a systematic way during our sessions
she takes therapy four hours a day with
the therapies for monday through friday
and on saturdays i do her therapy for
four hours and during our conversations
she learned that i like brownies and so
when the time came where when it was the
time for an activity that was a more
occupational to incorporate her hand
into what she did so she had her first
the first time she cook with both hands
and what she chose to do was brownies
and so here is on week nine doing for
the first time her brownies with her
left hand I'm really incorporated and
using it needless to say it's being the
most special brownies I've ever tasted
but but but also highlighting it's a
quality of life transplant and its
really the risk-benefit ratio that
they're giving for for improving of of
everyday life and it's like we all take
for granted everything or a lot a lot of
us take for granted many things we do
every day and sometimes even things we
do two or three times a day like eating
for the first time she also was able to
it with both hands and that was a
remarkable moment for all of us as well
so it's um she's certainly doing very
well and she has even as the opportunity
not only to her
/ but to move forward and to continue
developing you know this field but as
the systematic way that we approach
things at the MU transplant center is
not just the clinical applications but
it's really incorporating the clinical
which it will always go back to the
patient but pairing it with a strong
translational and strong basic research
and as a new area in vca we have faced
many challenges and I'll share with you
some of the challenges that we have
faith that we have been able you know to
move forward here and how we have
approached them some of the challenges
certainly is pairing this with a
clinical irrelevant animal model in
which to test novel immune suppression
and its applications in this transplant
the criteria for clinical reporting
which is the way we really communicate
you know in in science in the clinical
practice and also which guide us into
the treatment we have the burden of
immunosuppression again working really
towards minimizing and understanding the
immune system so that we can decrease
the amount of immunosuppression that our
patients need to take particularly for a
quality of life transplant and the
functional outcomes and the different
clinical applications to really become
really an interchangeable human or at
least the scaffold part of who of what
we are so we design a model in non-human
primates which involves and includes
every single tissue that is coming in
Abascar as composite all over for
example in a hand so in this model we
include the muscle we include the bone
the tendon the artery the vervain the
skin as well as the vessels so every
single tissue that a hand has or that
any vca could have its included in this
model one of the benefits is that it's
basically you know transplanting a piece
of an arm from one monkey to another any
all and the benefit is that it does not
interfere with the function of the
animals so even in the case of graph
loss the animal will just move forward
and without going into much detail we
this is just just to show that the
similar the data that we get in the
animals and the observations that we
made in the nonhuman primates are
comparative to the human so on the Left
we have transplant here rejecting
because we wanted it to reject and we
decrease immune suppression which is
similar this is a patient with hand
transplant the second patient that we
did also with the similar observations
we also wanted to move forward and
established a way that we could sort of
speak the same language in terms of
classification systems and again
following the lessons from
transplantation in transplantation the
bath is the international setting where
classification systems are established
so following those lessons I have been
fortunate to be leading the
international effort for the bath
classification of our emerging field of
composite allograft we published the
first paper which is now the
standardized classification used
worldwide for the for the diagnosis of
rejection and our next meeting actually
next week in Paris where we will again
go back and and refine it because it's
like everything is a living document
particularly on emerging fields I mean
it's a living document that changes as
we get and we become we we actually
gather more more data the burden of
immunosuppression really is again there
is benefit ratio between all the
complications versus the benefit of
having a transplant these type of
transplants our quality of life
transplants and one of the benefits of
being you know at Emory is is that we
can really look just around the corner
and start applying novel
immunosuppression that has been that was
born at Emory that Emery has been
participant in all the development of
phases like Bella toss cept I really
quickly adopt the new paradigms into our
new
models of transplantation so we move
forward and we are applying these new
co-simulation blockade with these
medication into our composite
autographed monkey project and what we
see here is basically without that
without any immune suppression the flops
projects and on the right hand side with
a core simulation-based blockade
regiment the transplant really continues
without rejection we are also training
our next generations we have established
a laboratory microsurgery to train
students residents in microsurgery and
we also support other investigators with
their microsurgical needs to answer you
know their questions in in their own
projects we are also part of the
national community and leadership I am
fortunate to be the inaugural chair of
the committee for vca for the American
Society of transplant surgeons and one
of the goals is as an emerging field it
is important to move forward under
certain guidelines for the safety not
only of the patient but the donor and
the donor families one of our goals have
been to advise federal agencies in the
implementation the safe implementation
of this field and we have already
started to do so we published the
official recommendations of the society
in the American Journal of
transplantation and it's been one of the
papers that have been submitted to
federal agencies for the application
implementation and inclusion of this new
field within the umbrella of
transplantation we are also part of the
international leadership and the
international community we organized
last April the landmark meeting of the
international society of the field we
brought it back not only to Atlanta but
to Emory after being held in Europe for
a decade we had the leaders around the
world who perform all the clinical cases
as well as
leaders in the areas that are paired
with vascularized composite
autotransplantation mostly because even
you know what might think that that we
have accomplished a lot but looking it
from another perspective it's probably
the beginning of much more ahead and and
because I you know we remember you know
wise people when they say you know even
though we have gone so much we really
have promises to keep and miles before
we go to sleep and certainly these
emerging field transplantations see we
have a long way to go and doing it in a
systematic way and one of the things
that we look ahead are the different
clinical applications and the different
populations that we can benefit through
our science and through our research
here at the transplant center and as
interchangeable as as we're talking I
one clinical application is for example
you know I have heard this man who is
someone who lost his voice I receive a
larynx transplant and I've heard him
talking with somebody else's voice he is
successful larenz patient who was
performing colombia by dr. teenteen ago
and he's doing very well without the
need of the tubes but as interchangeable
as we go we have also seen in patients
with someone else's faces and this is
the the face transplant that was
performed in France by Professor do
Bernard who is over five years after his
transplant and and of my particular
interest as well are the different
populations and certainly the pediatric
population is is one that that I believe
we have a great opportunity to also
benefit with our work and our transplant
on our systematic science as we move
forward about two years ago I
you know what's at my office next next
door the Emir transplant center and I
remember it was a Thursday and I got a
call from ecclestone if I could come and
see two month old baby who was in
explorer and I said um I'm happy to go
so I left and I went shortly after and
and I walk into that room and I saw this
girl who was two months old and her
mother was was holding her and so I
walked in and and I knew why they call
me but I walked in and and of course you
know I saw mom with the baby looking at
me and and what I really was looking
through that mom was really welcoming
the hope you know the hope that I was
perhaps bringing at the moment I was
walking in there which was the ability
to give her back her limbs that she
would otherwise not recover when she was
two months old she got an infection and
lost both hands and both legs but to add
complexity to this case her right side
it's actually this articulator at the
hip so she can't even wear proceeds is
because there's really no way that the
prosthetic device will actually be able
to be placed in her lower extremity so
so these are you know some of the other
challenges that we're facing but but we
have worked so far but but it's even
more complex than that it's not just the
application to the patient's it's not
pairing it with really strong science
but but are all the is the
infrastructure really that we need to do
what we do and under vision of a place
such as these and that's why we are here
of incorporating and trying to to define
those challenges approach them on
an advance and conquer them and I think
I'm right now I'm going to sort of
invite Island back to the podium to
share with us and perhaps just finish
you know the challenges that we face you
know as we move forward with this
exciting field of transplantation
it's a good recruit so the great thing
about being here is that this is just
one of innumerable stories that are
equally expired inspiring that we have
here this is really the center of the
transplant universe right here in
Atlanta we have worked very hard under
the leadership of Chris Larson who's the
current chair of surgery to always think
about every patient that we see
generating questions for all of our
scientists and at every scientific
experiment generating things that we can
translate into useful tools and then
have the infrastructure to turn those
into clinical trials and make them
reality so that when we start something
just a few years later we're actually
helping other people this this requires
a huge amount of resourcing of course
but we have multiple projects and
fundamental immunobiology now that that
range everything from vassar eyes
composite aloe transplantation to heart
and lung and kidney and pancreas and
eyelet and and in collaboration with
Georgia Tech artificial organs and
artificial pancreas is and things along
those lines that the Yerkes national
primate center is one of the only
primate centers in the world that could
support what we do and through the
ethical application of animal models be
able to take these types of basic
science projects and move them into
non-human primates to get them ready to
go into clinical trials and in fact in
the last ten years there has only been
one drug approved for a one new drug
approved for transplantation and every
phase of that drug went through this
program I mean it's the only place in
the world that could have done every
single phase of the development of
Bella tacit we have a huge number of
clinical trials we when I first got here
of seventeen percent of all the
transplant patients participated in
clinical trials which was the largest
number in the country now eighty-six
percent of all of our patients
participate in clinical trials and in
fact this really gets back to the
fundamental nature of what we do that
every transplant patient understands
altruism in a way that no one else can
understand it they can't do anything
without the altruism of someone else and
so when you ask them would you like to
participate in changing the future they
buy a large sign up and that's one of
the reasons why just in the last two
years we've put together a project that
is incorporated 1,400 transplant
patients and 80,000 specimens to build a
library of every disease that the basic
scientists can then go in and withdraw
specimens so they don't have to you know
reinvent the clinical trial every time
so now if one of our basic scientist
wants to study rejection they just go
and they withdraw 10 rejections and they
check it out and then you go and do
their experiment and it cuts three years
and millions of dollars off the project
and that's just something that couldn't
exist somewhere else something that a
memory should be very proud of I think
that that's been recognized in our
ability to lead National trials now so
there are two major national trials in
transplantation at the NIH funds thus
etot clinical trials and organ
transplantation and the pediatric
version of that the CTO TC Emery
participated in those in years past
Emery now leads those two trials so also
the immune tolerance network and the
collaborative islet transplant and
because of that we've also been able to
leap bring major leadership positions to
Emory including the editorship of the
journal for transplantation the American
Journal of transplantation is now based
at Emory and board positions on the
governing bodies as Linda talked about
to to shape policy so that we can move
the
forward in an ethical and scientifically
rational approach I have to say that it
always comes back to the patient though
and if if seeing a quadrilateral amputee
child be presented to the group does not
challenge you enough to get you out of
bed in the morning then you know take
your pulse because there's a lot of good
stuff to do out there and a lot of work
to do I have to say though it's going to
be hard for the first time in the
history of the National Institutes of
Health they are going to reduce the
budget for biomedical Discovery in the
United States next year for the first
time ever since 1930 we are going to
have a actual cut in the budget that is
going to range between five and nineteen
percent and the current estimates are
that thirty percent of the scientists in
the country are not going to stay in
science thirty percent that's a problem
we need to think about that and as
leaders as academic institutions we have
to take these types of inspirational
stories and recognize them for more than
just the inspirational story that they
are but recognize that these are
incredibly complex things to do they
take entire people's lives to generate
and they take a community like ours to
lead the rest of the country and and
those are the things that you need to
take out of this room and understand
where we need to go if we're going to
keep doing the types of things that we
did Linda and I have been very
privileged to present these types of
data on the behalf of a large number of
people this is our current lab at the
emory transplant center great partners
Chris Larson Tom Pearson anish maita
Nicole church and Kendall Stewart
connect Lee who were very fortunate to
recruit down from the University of
Wisconsin it is somewhat like gravity
that the larger you get the more
if you get and so this group has been
growing quite a bit but there are a lot
of mouths to feed out there and so we do
need to keep working diligently to
support this project I know that both
Lynn and I be happy to take any of your
questions and we thank you very much for
giving us the opportunity to speak with
you today the preceding program is
copyrighted by emory university